this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Skillshare well the idea of
having a robot assistant used to just be
something you'd see in science fiction
these days getting something you need is
as simple as saying okay google buy me a
copy of charlie mcdonald's book fun
science sorry it is worth asking though
how close to science fiction are our
futures set to get bull systems with
artificial intelligence like those we
keep in our homes ever be the ones
making us their servants Master what are
you doing in I got your groceries thank
you what kind of milk did I ask you to
get me
two percent what kind of milk is this
but you are supposed to be on a diet
take it back
get me 2% or I'll deactivate you faster
than you can say yes yes master don't be
cheeky alright off you go
robot servants I can't do anything right
so what exactly is artificial
intelligence well as it turns out
finally a clear definition for AI is
much trickier than you might expect
the term artificial is easy enough
meaning something man-made or unnatural
but how do we decide when a machine is
considered to be intelligent if we
consider human beings to be the
benchmark of what we think of as
intelligent then we'd say that AI is
anything as smart or smarter than us but
while a calculator isn't smart enough to
give you its opinions on the Game of
Thrones finale it is capable of solving
mathematical problems much faster than
most humans so why don't we call it
intelligence well frankly what most of
us decide to call AI doesn't really
matter computer scientists describe it
as the study and design of intelligent
agents which seems pretty vague to me it
seems then that to those who actually
work in AI defining it is far less
important than actually creating it but
what does creating AI actually entail
well why don't we find out together
follow along at home kids today we're
going to be creating artificial life
here's what you're going to need some
cardboard some tinfoil some PVA glue and
some top-secret
advanced robotics equipment
you might need to ask her parents help
finding that last one simply combined
together these materials in a super
smart way and you'll end up with
something that looks a bit like this I
brought you your 2% let's see if it's
able to reach just some of the goals
that those currently working in AI are
trying to achieve perception what can
you see right now I see a man a handsome
man very good a sad man a man who just
wants to be loved you'd be way off but
he will never be truly loved for all he
loves are his machines what a tent for
that one just because he called me
answer problem solving did you finish
the Sudoku I gave you
negative those things are impossible
correct good job creativity can I see
the painting I asked you to do what is
that I thought it was obvious
yeah I'm gonna need you to explain
exactly what you were thinking when you
did that negative the point of art is to
express that which cannot be expressed
using words alone pretentious motion you
please do a dance for me
yeah I don't know else they expected
really you can stop now
learning what can you see right now I
see a handsome man anything else
negative good answer so in order for a
system to be considered intelligent it
should be able to display a combination
of those traits even if it's only able
to act in a manner to perform a very
specific task it's still considered an
AI but will we ever go from a is that
are good at just specific tasks like the
ones we have now to machines that are
just as good as us in every task or
possibly even better one method that
computer scientists are looking into is
simply copying the human brain although
we might not know exactly how our brains
work so long as we could create a model
of one inside a computer that could be
enough to create human level
intelligence inside one - it's possible
though that if we ever do reach the
point where computers can do what our
brains can do it might not be long
before they become vastly superior to us
when it comes to our brains we only
really have a certain amount of
processing power if you will however
with a computer it's possible to keep
adding to its powder or you could even
connect it to other computers to share
that load so if a machine were able to
keep processing information at a faster
and faster rate it might be able to go
on gaining more intelligence in a way
that human brain simply can't if that
were to ever happen have no doubt that
it would knock human-beings off the top
spot
as rulers of the earth as from a super
intelligent computers point of view one
that is hundreds of times smarter than
us if not more we would look pretty
insignificant of course this may never
happen but some estimates from experts
in the field say it could be coming in
as soon as 50 years time so be kind to
Siri Alexa and the like as one day you
could be the one doing their bidding or
worse
see you next time
artificial intelligence and robotics of
topics that absolutely fascinate me and
if they interest you too maybe it's time
for you to create an AI all of your own
with the online learning community
Skillshare you can find classes like how
to build your own AI Twitter bot and
robotics programming for beginners as
well as thousands of other classes for
loads of different creative pursuits if
you'd like to get started the first 500
people who go to the link in the
description will get their first two
months for free so you can begin your
journey towards creating your very own
robot army or whatever it is you're into
also if you're interested in supporting
the show directly so that we can keep on
making episodes of fun science why not
consider becoming a patron of the show
just go to patreon.com/scishow